Harry: From Christmas
pizzas to "Elf" doughnuts,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between fast-food holiday
menus in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Let's start with some
McDonald's seasonal items.
In the UK we actually
have quite a few of these.
We're going to start
with the chicken Big Mac.
They brought this into the
UK menu, like, a year ago
as a kind of temporary thing,
and it was really popular.
It is a Big Mac, but
instead of the beef patties
you have chicken patties.
So it goes bun, patty,
lettuce, sauce, pickles,
the middle bun, the patty, cheese,
pickles, sauce, and lettuce.
Mm-hmm. Obviously, like,
the ratio, I think,
of the Big Mac has been
perfected over the years,
so they haven't messed with that too much.
My only real complaint is that
instead of an actual
piece of chicken breast,
it's like a big, very flat chicken nugget.
I also have some questions
as to how festive this is
and why it's on the festive menu.
Obviously the box is kind
of, like, festive design.
I mean, what is a chicken
if not just a small turkey?
Next up we have the big and cheesy,
not the big cheesy, the big and cheesy.
Look at that.
And we also have the
big cheesy with bacon.
You have a beef patty, you
have two slices of cheese,
you have red onions, crispy onions,
lettuce, and cheese sauce.
I mean, I like cheese, I
like onions, I like beef.
It's also served in a bun
which they describe as
"snowflake-flour-dusted,"
which I guess is maybe their attempt
at making this actually festive
and justifying its inclusion on the menu.
Mm. The star of the show for me
is actually the cheese sauce
that they've added there.
Personally, I'm a big fan.
I think it's great. Adds a lovely texture
and really I guess slightly fake
but very comforting cheesy
flavor to the burger.
In the UK at McDonald's we
usually have mozzarella sticks
as kind of a permanent menu item,
but for Christmas they turn into these,
these cheese melt dippers.
These are Camembert instead of mozzarella.
They usually come with
a tomato dip as well,
although I think they forgot ours.
I will usually go out of my way
to try and find these
around Christmas in the UK.
As with pretty much anything
that is made with fried cheese,
they're much better eaten fresh and hot.
Still a little bit gooey and very tasty.
Camembert has such a lovely flavor.
I think I consider Brie cheese
festive, strangely enough.
Not usually Camembert, although
I think it's traditional
to have a cheese board around Christmas,
so maybe Camembert is included
on that and we can allow it.
The other hot food option we can get
but we didn't get today is
the McDonald's chicken combo.
This includes 10 chicken selects,
which are kind of like
our chicken tenders,
20 chicken nuggets, four select dips,
which are like fancier
versions of the dip,
and then four regular dips.
It's designed to serve around four people.
The next menu item is the first
of a kind of themed batch.
Basically what they've done is
incorporate Galaxy chocolate
into various McDonald's menu items.
Galaxy, for those who don't know,
is kind of the Mars corporation's
answer to Dairy Milk.
There's a bit of a divide in the UK
as to whether you're Galaxy or Dairy Milk
when it comes to your milk chocolate.
So, this is the Galaxy caramel pie.
So what they do is they
take the apple pie shell,
put some chocolate in that dough, fry it,
and then instead of the apple sauce
you have caramel sauce on the inside.
I mean, I love McDonald's
apple pies. They're so good.
I don't really want to
mess with the formula.
I think, for me, I still
just want the apple pie.
I don't think this beats
an apple pie for me.
Then we have a Galaxy chocolate McFlurry.
Again, it's just kind
of a standard McFlurry,
but with these actually
very cute chocolate stars
which are made of Galaxy chocolate.
In addition to the
Galaxy chocolate options,
they also have Galaxy caramel options.
You can find these in
the form of the McFlurry,
but also in the form of a caramel latte
and also a caramel hot chocolate.
I'm also not sure why Galaxy
or Galaxy caramel are festive.
I guess we eat a lot of
chocolate around the holidays.
But specifically Galaxy? Eh, not so sure.
I wish our McDonald's had as many
holiday additions as the UK does,
but we only have one,
and it's the holiday pie.
So it's like their regular pie crust
and what looks like a
bunch of rainbow sprinkles
and some sort of creamy,
maybe custardy filling.
What's inside? Well ...
I don't think this will live up
to the apple pie at all, actually.
Just get the apple pie.
As always, Starbucks has
gone big for the holidays.
In the US, you can get a bunch
of limited-edition food and drink options.
Let's start with the drinks.
I love this job!
We have so many hot and iced
drinks, couldn't get them all.
Here is a fantastic
selection of said drinks.
I'm just going to start down here, y'all.
The caramel brulée latte.
Better than you think.
In other holiday episodes
you've probably seen me
really "bah, humbug"
a lot of these drinks,
but maybe I'm getting older,
maybe I'm getting kinder,
or maybe this show has
completely destroyed my palate,
but either way, I kind of like that.
Next up, the sugar
cookie almond milk latte.
"Sugar cookie" apparently is
just a shorthand for "sweet."
This is pretty sweet.
I'm kind of getting an almond
flavor from it in the latte,
but it really just tastes
like a sweet latte.
I don't dislike it but, eh, just OK.
Next up is the chestnut praline latte.
We've been doing this for three years now,
this might be the fourth,
and I still am not quite
clear on what a praline is.
If you handed this to me, I'd be like,
yeah, it's got a kind of
a nutty latte taste to it,
but I could also see this being
just another almond latte.
Yeah, these two are very, very similar.
Unless you have a taste
for chestnuts and praline
or a chestnut praline, eh, skip it.
Gingerbread latte.
Yeah, man.
Very gingerbready. Not to be
confused with just ginger,
definitely generous with the bread part.
What?
Oh, man, these lattes are
hitting, boy. They are hitting.
Gingerbread oat milk chai.
I really like this. You're so good.
The ginger, yes. The bread, yes.
The oat milk, oh, yeah.
And the chai, oh, the chai.
Fantastic. That might be my favorite one.
So, of course you can get this one iced.
Ooh, ice. Look, they even put the little
nutmeg or whatever on
top. Or is it cinnamon?
What is that? Do you know what that is?
Yeah. Hope that's supposed to be in there.
No, not as good as this one.
This, of course, is not the only
holiday drinks at Starbucks.
Depending where you are in the world
or where you are in California,
or where you are in Burbank,
California, specifically,
you can get any variety of these.
The Oleato gingerbread oat milk latte,
that's the one with olive oil.
I would suggest you avoid those.
Iced sugar cookie latte, peppermint mocha,
white chocolate mocha,
peppermint mocha iced,
also known as an iced peppermint mocha.
Caramel brulée Frappuccino,
white chocolate mocha Frappuccino,
iced caramel brulée latte,
chestnut praline Frappuccino,
peppermint mocha Frappuccino,
and an iced peppermint mocha.
Here are all the Starbucks
exclusive holiday items
that you'll find in the UK but not the US.
As usual, Starbucks has
gone big for the holidays.
A few of these are familiar ones
that we might have
covered in previous years,
but there are a couple
of new additions as well.
We'll start with the hot drinks,
where we have a couple of options
which you'll only find
around the holidays.
Obviously all of these are also served
in the Starbucks holiday cup,
but first we have an eggnog latte.
This is one that we've
had before in the UK.
Eggnog, not super popular in the UK.
I gather, like, not even
that popular in the US.
I think it's just, like, a few people
are kind of holding on
to it as a tradition.
It's OK. It's not offensive by any means,
it's just a sort of spiced,
almost custardy but just kind of
just like a spiced milky
latte. Doesn't taste of egg.
Then we have a toffee nut latte,
which is another returning drink.
God. Every year I get my
hopes up about this one,
thinking it's going to be good,
because I like toffee, I like nuts,
and then I take my
first sip, and good God.
If you've ever been
trying to toast hazelnuts,
for example, and you've burned them,
that's what this tastes like.
It's just a very sweet latte
that tastes like burned hazelnuts.
Next up we have the caramel waffle latte,
which is another returner.
Does it taste of waffle?
Not really.
I think they almost mean
more like the stroopwafel
that you might find in the Netherlands
rather than a sort of breakfast waffle,
but it doesn't really taste
of either of those things,
it just kind of tastes of caramel.
So those first three
drinks we've had before,
but we have two new drinks this year.
Firstly, we have the hazelnut
crunch hot chocolate.
Hm, OK.
So, there are things floating in it,
which I think at one point
might have been crunchy.
However, you don't have
to be a genius to know
that when you put
crunchy things in liquid,
they often soften.
Maybe go back to the
research and development
until you can find a
hydrophobic crunchy substance.
And then our next new drink
is the chocolaty gingerbread latte.
Let's see how they've managed to
marry these three beverages.
Not well is the answer to that.
[crew laughs]
It's mostly gingerbread
with a kind of, like,
that bitterness from the coffee.
Also, just a quick note, if you
have the venti eggnog latte,
that contains 52.8 grams of sugar,
which is more than 100% of
your daily recommended intake.
Probably my last eggnog
latte of the season.
And for the festive treats
at Starbucks in the US,
you can get, in no particular order,
this peppermint brownie cake pop.
The Cranberry Bliss Bar. We got a slice;
you can also get this in
its whole tray in box form.
And a sugarplum cheese Danish.
You know, I'm curious about this cake pop.
Yeah, that's nice. I like that.
So good.
I'm not getting sugarplum
specifically out of it,
but, yeah, cheese Danish
with a nice little jam in the center.
Why not, right?
Also, depending where
you are in the country,
you can get a snowman cookie
or a gingerbread loaf.
This year I think we might actually have
more festive items than
America, which is pretty cool.
Doesn't happen often on "Food Wars."
We'll start with the sandwiches.
Here we have a turkey
and chicken sandwich.
There's also bacon, some
stuffing, some cranberry sauce,
as well as some spinach in there.
It seems a bit weird to
combine very similar meats.
I guess maybe people make a turducken
and all that sort of stuff,
but I think just have one or the other.
Just have, like, a good turkey sandwich.
Next up, we have the holiday ham sub roll.
Sub roll, submarine roll,
because the bun is supposed to look
slightly like a submarine.
This one has honey-roast ham,
mature cheddar cheese, honey,
and a mustard slaw with
cranberry chutney and spinach.
The default seems to be adding
spinach and cranberry chutney
to all of these to make them festive.
I'm slightly more into
the hot sandwich options,
so here we have the
pigs-under-blankets sandwich.
[grunts]
Obviously in the UK we
have pigs in blankets,
which are sausages wrapped in bacon,
rather than the American way,
which is wrapping a
sausage in some pastry.
These aren't pigs in blankets
because the sausages aren't wrapped.
They are pigs under
blankets because I think
the bacon is added as a
separate layer on top,
although it's kind of
hermetically sealed itself
to the bread and I can't get it off.
We've obviously got the
sausages and the bacon here,
but there's also some cheddar
cheese, some stuffing,
some cranberry sauce as well.
It's gone a little bit
dry now that it's cold,
but I actually quite like that.
I think the bread is good.
It's crunchy on the outside
but nice and chewy on the inside.
The pork sausages have a good flavor.
You could even go more
generous with the mayo.
And I think that's actually a
pretty good festive sandwich.
Next up we have the Brie
and cranberry focaccia.
I think this used to be
called the cranmerry focaccia,
but they've changed it
and just gone straight down the middle,
let people know what they're getting.
It's a sandwich with some Brie,
the cranberry chutney, more spinach again.
They must have a surplus
of spinach this year.
And it's all served on
this rosemary focaccia.
The focaccia is really dry.
That might be mitigated
if you eat it in store
and it's freshly heated.
But, like, the pigs-under-blankets roll
still kind of held up, whereas that is
quite difficult to eat
when it's cold, so ...
And then the final hot option we have
is the festive feast panini.
Ta-da!
Firstly, this is actually chicken,
this isn't turkey.
We have bacon, there's some stuffing,
there's a turkey gravy on here,
some cranberry sauce as well,
and then it's all kind of melted together
with some cheddar cheese.
We love a panini in the UK.
They're really popular on café menus
as a hot sandwich option.
The fillings work pretty well together.
Again, could probably stand to go
for slightly more moisture,
I think the theme has just
been a bit dry so far.
And then we have some sweet
baked seasonal goods from Starbucks.
I'm going to request a quick
in memoriam section here
because for the first time in
a few years of doing these,
we don't have South Pole Sam.
My son has vanished.
I'm hoping it's a brief hiatus
rather than a permanent goodbye.
I hope he's good wherever he is,
with North Pole Nat as well.
Hope they're living off
their dreams together.
This one's for you, buddy.
Starbucks does have quite a few
baked-good options here
in the UK for Christmas.
We have the Christmas tree brownie.
Does what it says on the tin.
It's a brownie in the
shape of a Christmas tree.
We have the caramel waffle muffin.
This is what I was talking about
when I said the caramel waffle latte
I think was based on these.
So, this is what the Dutch
would call a stroopwafel.
It's these very thin,
almost biscuity layers
with a layer of caramel inside.
If you go to Amsterdam,
get yourself some fresh stroopwafels.
You'll have a good time.
Then you also have some toffee icing,
and then inside there's some molten toffee
in the middle as well.
It's a pretty good muffin.
This is the toffee nut cookie,
or at least half of it.
Then finally we have two cookie options.
We have, of course, the
classic Starbucks bearista,
but he's been given a holiday makeover.
Domino's has brought back
its Christmas pizza for 2023.
The fact that they've brought this back
does suggest that some
people are actually buying it
and that it's a commercial
success for them,
which I'm a little bit confused by
because I don't think I've
ever enjoyed this thing.
Its official name is the festive one,
and it contains a cranberry
drizzle, some bacon rashers,
some pulled sage and onion
turkey, onions, and sausage.
Weirdly, the thing I
probably object to the most
is the red onion on here.
The cranberry sauce I can
almost kind of deal with.
I don't remember exactly how
I reacted to it last time,
but it's very sweet.
I will say I quite like
the flavor of the turkey.
You definitely get the sage and onion,
which is what we would typically include
in stuffing in the UK.
And the sausage and the
bacon are just kind of there.
I just think there is way
better pizzas on the menu.
The best thing I can say about it
is that I think it looks quite pretty.
What actually does kind of excite me
on the Domino's menu, though,
is their new seasonal desserts.
These are their twisted
chocolate cinnamon dough balls.
I think basically what they
do is just take their dough,
twist it into these kind of
twisted dough ball shapes,
bake it, and then top it
with various seasonings.
In this case there's chocolate
sauce and cinnamon sugar.
I mean, I love dough balls,
I love chocolate sauce,
and I love cinnamon, so ...
Mm-hmm.
I love the texture of dough balls.
I love the crunch on the outside
and the chew you get in the middle.
I think if I were ordering at
Domino's in the festive period
and I wanted to feel festive,
I would swerve the pizza
and instead just get these.
When it comes to the holiday season,
the US loves to add peppermint
into pretty much everything,
and Wendy's is no exception.
So we have the peppermint
Frosty cream cold brew
and the actual peppermint Frosty.
I've never had Wendy's coffee
before, so I'm very intrigued.
I actually like the taste of the coffee,
I just feel like there's
very little flavor payoff
from the Frosty that's
added into the coffee.
I'm mostly tasting coffee.
Moving on, we're going to try
the actual peppermint Frosty.
It basically tastes like
a less serious version
of mint chocolate chip ice cream,
so it just has no chocolate chips
and it's just the ice cream
part. It's pretty good.
It's not my favorite Frosty
flavor I've ever tried,
but it's a fun holiday flavor.
KFC has also added a few new things
to its Christmas menu in the UK this year.
We'll start with this,
the gravy triple bucket.
It's one big sharing item.
In here you get, bear with me,
six pieces of Original Recipe chicken,
one regular popcorn
chicken, eight hot wings,
six mini fillets, two large gravy sides,
four fries, and a drink,
and it comes with instructions
to "let the gravy flow."
The bucket's quite fun.
Otherwise, they haven't
made too much effort.
They actually made a point this year
of kind of addressing the demands
for them to do turkey at Christmas,
and just said that, "Actually, no.
We do chicken. We're going
to stick to our guns.
Stick to what we know best."
This whole thing will set
you back around £28.99,
which is quite a lot of money,
although I think it's
probably designed to be shared
between four or five people,
so per-person cost, not too bad.
We have two festive burger
options, starting with this one,
the stuffing tower burger.
So, usually at the UK KFC,
we will have a tower burger on the menu.
However, outside the festive period,
this just means that
they've added a hash brown
into a regular chicken burger.
For the festive period, however,
the hash brown is gone, and
it's been replaced by this,
which is a sage and onion stuffing patty.
I will say, looking at the color of this,
that doesn't look like any
sage and onion stuffing
that I've ever had in my entire life.
We have some cranberry sauce
for some extra festive twang,
and that's all layered on top
of a pretty regular KFC chicken sandwich.
So you have a cheesy chicken fillet,
some lettuce, and some mayo.
I do not think that a patty
is the optimal delivery form
for sage and onion stuffing.
I say bring back the hash browns.
And the other option is the
stuffing stacker burger.
So, a stacker burger in the UK at KFC
is basically just a double burger.
As you can see, it's got two of these
chicken fillets with the cheese.
And, once again, our old friend,
the stuffing patty.
I think for a chain that's clearly put
some thought into their
Christmas offerings,
in terms of the packaging
and including things like
cranberry sauce and stuffing,
I think I'm disappointed
with the end result.
KFC, of course, has a
few festive menu items,
nothing really in the chicken department.
What they do have, and
they do this every year,
is a festive bucket for the chicken.
It looks cool. I think
they always do a good job
with the design on this.
You got a sentient bucket of chicken there
with arms and legs. That's bizarre.
If you see the drum playing itself
with drumsticks, wah-wah-wah,
and of course the centerpiece
is this really cool tree.
I'm not complaining, because
look what's in the bucket.
I want to say I would've liked to see them
maybe introduce some
sort of limited-edition,
I don't know, Christmas extra spicy.
I don't know. Hey, I
don't work at R&D for KFC,
so I'm sure there's a reason
they didn't do it. Money.
The only new menu item is this.
It is the mac and cheese chicken wrap.
Come on. It was already in every store.
Let's just put it on the menu.
Wraps, had them. Chicken, had it.
Mac and cheese, had it.
Put it together, new menu item!
I mean, who am I kidding? That's great.
It's their chicken,
it's crispy, I love it.
It's their mac and cheese, which is great.
It's in a wrap, which I don't
object to really, so ...
Speaking of not-holiday-specific,
at least I don't think,
there's the colonel's homestyle brownie.
Yo, brownies. I mean, could this be
on the menu all year round? Yeah.
But just the holidays, fine.
KFC always releases supercool
merch around the holidays.
I was given a budget of up to $40,
and the only thing that I could get
that fell into that budget
was this fun holiday bucket hat.
Same idea as the bucket.
You got a tree, you got a
snowman, you got french fries,
and you got these guys making a snowman,
and then you got what
appears to be a snowman
that is self-aware.
I just don't like wearing hats, really.
This is as far down as I can get it.
Both of my coworkers are laughing at me,
so I can only assume I look great.
Let's be honest, internet.
Let's get a poll going.
Can I rock this look?
Holiday stuff aside, is
Joe a bucket-hat guy?
Where are my bucket-hat-heads at?
In the comments, let me know.
New look, or put it in the trash?
Honestly, I think that
merch looks kind of sick,
and I kind of want some.
KFC, you know where to find me.
Here are all of our exclusive
festive drinks from Dunkin'.
So, the first drink we have is
the cookie butter cold brew.
It has this stuff at the bottom
that I think is the cookie
butter syrup, but it's very dark.
I mean, it's good, but like
every other drink at Dunkin',
it is very, very sweet.
I do like that cookie butter
syrup, though. It's tasty.
It tastes like a gingerbread cookie.
This is an iced toasted
white chocolate latte.
It kind of tastes a little coconutty
but also a little buttery.
It's very odd. I don't love it.
Somebody out there will, though.
This is an iced peppermint mocha.
I love peppermint mocha, so
I'm hoping it's delicious.
I never get them iced, though.
I think they taste better hot.
Yeah, that's really good.
I'm surprised that the peppermint syrup
isn't as strong as other
peppermint mochas I've had
from other places,
because Dunkin' is known
for doing the most with the
syrups and all the flavors,
but this one's actually pretty mellow.
This is the spiced cookie
coffee, and I want it to be good.
I love spiced cookies. I
love gingerbread cookies.
It's not bad.
I think it needs some
sort of creamy element
to make it actually come together.
This is that same spiced
cookie coffee, except it's hot.
I think it'll taste better this way.
Yeah, I think I'm right.
Next, we have a hot
chocolate with peppermint.
That has a weird aftertaste
that I don't like.
So, this is a hot chocolate
with the toasted white chocolate syrup.
Same thing. What is going on
with the Dunkin' hot chocolates?
Why are they so oily-tasting?
This is the brown sugar cookie iced chai.
This looks really good.
I feel like this looks like a good color.
This is the difference between
a coffee that you know is going to be bad
and something that looks pretty good.
This color theory only applies
to Dunkin', by the way.
I feel like if you go to Dunkin' a lot,
you know exactly what I'm talking about.
Delicious. Delicious,
delicious, wonderful.
It is a little overly sweet.
I've just come to get used to that
when it comes to Dunkin'
anything, but this is really good.
This is the exact same thing but hot,
the brown sugar cookie chai.
Whoa, no. Iced, it's really delicious.
This is the toasted white
chocolate coconut cold brew.
I'm not a huge fan of coconut.
That's not bad.
I do feel like with some of these drinks,
the iced version is the way to go
just because it helps it not be so sweet.
This is the brown sugar
cookie frozen coffee.
I love all of the Dunkin' frozen coffees.
I think they're so tasty, and
they're basically Coolattas.
They just don't call it that anymore.
This is so yummy.
Next, we have the toasted
white chocolate iced coffee.
This looks like a pretty good color.
Are we seeing the color theory?
Are we seeing what I mean?
So, at Dunkin', if you get
something with a swirl,
that means it's a
sweetened flavor additive,
versus the flavor shots,
which are just the flavor
with no added sugar.
I kind of prefer those to the swirls
just because you can
overdo the swirls so easily
and the whole thing
just becomes too sweet,
but this one is actually
a pretty good balance.
And last but not least,
we have a peppermint mocha hot coffee.
The cream that's in it isn't doing enough
to make it a creamy,
full-bodied kind of beverage.
It's too watery.
I got it on my pants. Help!
And here we have all of the
festive food exclusives at Dunkin'.
I'm going to start with
these loaded hash browns.
They're calling my name.
I'm a big fan of Dunkin' hash browns.
So, this is just their regular hash browns
covered with jalapeño cheddar queso
and some chopped-up bacon bits.
This smells amazing.
And it's all congealed.
Just give me a moment.
I do wish that there was a better ratio
of queso to actual hash browns.
It's all a little bit dry.
It's a little salty, but
it tastes good to me.
Like, I could eat this
whole thing in five minutes.
Moving on, we have two wraps.
One of these is chorizo and egg,
and the other is chicken
and roasted pepper.
I'm not sure which is which,
so let's taste them both.
Let's start with this one,
the one that's not a
radioactive orange color.
It's not bad. I think it's
missing a bit of salt,
but it's actually got a nice heat to it,
which I wasn't expecting.
I would order this.
I'm assuming that this
is the chorizo and egg,
so let's taste it. Why it's so orange,
don't know.
We dye everything in this country, OK?
We dye all of our food.
Hm, I feel like it's a little bland.
I can't really taste much of
anything besides the chorizo.
This is the maple sugar snackin' bacon.
Dunkin' is the only place
I've ever seen offer bacon like this,
like, just a little pack of to-go bacon.
I assume it's going to be sweet.
Yeah, just tastes like sweet bacon.
It's kind of soggy.
It's bacon. It's going to
taste good. And it does.
I'm going to eat one more piece.
Next, we have the maple sugar bacon
breakfast sandwich on a croissant.
I really love getting Dunkin'
sandwiches on a croissant.
I think they toast them really well.
Maybe this one's a
little too well toasted.
It's a little burned.
Oh, you guys, that's a little ...
Oh, no. I think after opening it,
I don't want to take a bite of it,
so let's just move on to the next thing.
This is the ham and
Swiss croissant stuffer.
So, what I think they did
is just baked the ham and
Swiss inside the croissant
and then baked the
croissant instead of just
putting it into a croissant
sandwich like this.
I'm going to go for the middle
because I want the filling.
That was such a deep bite,
and I didn't get a lick of
that ham or that cheese.
I just want to -- oh, it's like deli ham.
I'm going to taste the ham.
I would never get it again, but it's fine.
One thing we're missing is
the triple-chocolate muffin,
which I ordered, but it didn't come,
so I guess they ran out.
It is a holiday exclusive
at Dunkin', though.
Krispy Kreme is celebrating
the 20th anniversary
of the movie "Elf" with
"Elf" doughnut collections.
I love it. I love "Elf." I just
think this is just the best.
Apparently Will Ferrell
held out for more money,
because he's not involved
in this holiday branding.
Fantastic movie. Twenty years
ago? Oh, God, I'm so old.
Anyway, let's take a
look at the doughnuts.
The Buddy snow globe doughnut,
the Buddy makes breakfast doughnut,
the Christmas lights doughnut,
and the Santa belly doughnut.
This is just so great. Isn't
this great? This is great.
So that's another Buddy one.
And again, really smart,
just the hat and the feet.
Don't need Will Ferrell. The Santa belly.
This is probably a
cream-filled one, right?
[sighs] Krispy Kreme is so good.
I could eat this whole
box while watching "Elf,"
and the second it ends,
being sad that "Elf" is over
and sad that I ate 12 doughnuts
will put me into a funk.
Hey, Krispy Kreme, fantastic.
And, of course, there are
limited-edition drinks
at Krispy Kreme this holiday season.
The main one is the sugar cookie latte,
which you can get hot, iced, or frozen.
And that, of course, is none of these!
According to the DoorDash guy,
this Krispy Kreme
specifically did not have
the sugar cookie stuff, so
he subbed it with peppermint.
Now, I looked online.
I didn't see peppermint in
the holiday-specific section,
but I didn't see peppermint
in the non-holiday-specific
section either,
so I'm going to assume that this is
in fact holiday-specific.
So we got a peppermint latte hotty boy.
Oh, whoa!
I do not like that, but look in my eyes.
If you really love peppermint,
you need to get this drink.
I'm mainlining peppermint
flavor right now.
I can't believe that.
I need to eat a candy
cane to bring me down
from how much peppermint
is in this. Good Lord.
How is it iced?
That can't be right.
Krispy Kreme just went,
"Forget it, we're targeting
the most specific audience
with these drinks."
People where things can't
be pepperminty enough,
your prayers have been answered.
You probably have noticed
Ghirardelli is a very popular
fancy chocolate brand.
Well, they have their own
Ghirardelli hot chocolate.
Could be "gear-ardelli." There's
an H. It's "jeer-ardelli."
Wow, this might be one of the best
hot chocolates I've ever had.
It is so smooth. It is
rich but not too rich.
This is way better than any
other hot chocolate I've had,
certainly anything you
get at a chain restaurant
or fast-food restaurant.
Krispy Kreme, I gotta say,
you get the W this season.
Beyond the fast-food restaurants,
we also have a bunch of items
that you'll find in supermarkets
in the UK around the holidays.
The giant Lindor ball is back.
This thing is great but also is always
a recipe for disappointment
because no matter how many times I see it,
I always think it's going to be
a giant chocolate ball, and it never is.
How many Lindor do you think
you actually get in one of these?
Ooh, actually that's
reasonably generous. Lindor?
I like that they've even shaped the ball
like a little Lindor, with
those little indentations.
Next up we have a
festive-edition Toblerone.
This is the orange twist flavor.
I don't know if these are
as big a thing in the US
as they are in the UK,
but people do love them
over here in the UK.
It's usually something that I
might receive maybe as a gift
or I will occasionally buy
in, like, an airport duty-free lounge.
I'm not a huge orange chocolate guy,
but, honestly, this is really good.
Gentle orangey flavor with
the Toblerone texture.
Thumbs-up from me.
Cadbury usually comes
up big for the holidays.
We've got a couple of items here,
including this lovely chocolate Santa,
which unfortunately is hollow.
But you can also buy
Christmas tree decorations from Cadbury.
It's a bag full of
little edible ornaments.
Do not eat the foil or the string,
but within there, there
is some milk chocolate.
Oreo also has their own house.
This is their prebuilt cookie house,
which is made of their cookies.
But we're going to start by tasting
some of their other holiday
stuff, like the snowballs.
They're a chocolate filled
with an Oreo filling.
Hold on. These look underfilled.
Awful. It doesn't taste
anything like Oreos to me.
Moving on to the actual cookies,
we have the classic holiday Oreos
that just have the red filling,
and then we have hot cocoa Oreos,
which I've never tried before.
Oreo is always trying
the weirdest flavor combinations to me.
Do you remember that they
did a Swedish Fish Oreo?
Look at those two layers in there.
I think that's a fun little touch.
Like all other Oreos, all
the cream goes to one side.
It's a better concept to me than it is
in actual cookie form.
Now, these I know and I love.
What the hell? The serving
size for Oreos is two.
In my brain I'm going to
believe that this was colored
with beet juice and not red dye 40.
I scrape all of the creme off, like that,
and then I eat the two cookies together.
Katya: Boo!
[crew laughs]
They booed Jesus too.
Moving on, we have the
white-fudge-covered Oreo,
so it's a regular Oreo
covered in this white fudge.
I've had these before,
and they're actually really, really good.
I think it's time to build
our Oreo cookie house.
So, it comes with a couple
of packs of plain Oreos
for you to decorate with.
So, I think that this
icing is actually flavored
just like the Oreo filling.
These little, I think they're gummy stars.
Look at these little
gingerbread men in there.
And then we have a couple of tubes
of red and green icing for
you to decorate with too,
and then we have the actual cookie house.
Oh, no! Our roof caved in a bit.
But it's OK, I think I can
fix it with some icing.
Oh, no, it turns out
that the icing in these
cookie-gingerbread-house-making
kits still sucks.
Skill level one. Really
easy. It's not true.
The doorknob is ginormous
compared to the door.
This is the hardest thing
I've ever done in my life.
They're already all broken.
Oh, my God, these stars are hard as rocks.
Stop zooming in on the house.
And here are all of the exclusive holiday
Hershey's chocolates that I could find.
So, first we have these bells
that are peppermint bark.
It's a white chocolate on top
and then a milk chocolate on the bottom.
That is so good.
Mm! These little sprinkles
that it has all throughout
adds a really, really nice texture.
These are the mint truffle Kisses.
So they have this mint
filling inside of them
that is green. That we'll skip.
And these are the candy cane Kisses,
which are also peppermint flavored,
and they have those little
sprinkles running throughout,
so I'm sure they taste
similar to the bells.
These are the cherry cordial Kisses.
On the outside it looks like
a regular chocolate Kiss,
but it's supposed to have
that cherry cordial filling.
Oh! Bleh! Mediciny.
So, these are the sugar cookie Kisses.
That's so good. It tastes like
cake batter, in a good way.
We have the hot cocoa Kisses,
which are really cute.
So it's milk chocolate with
marshmallow-flavored creme.
I know how weird it sounds to say this
as I'm eating chocolate candy,
but it's literally just too sweet for me.
We also have the Hershey's Kisses
that are cookies and cream,
which is basically like what their
cookies and cream bars taste
like, which is amazing.
Calories per pieces gives you seven.
You can have seven kisses,
and it's only 150 cals.
Tastes just like the
Hershey bar. It's amazing.
So, these are a little different.
These are Hershey's Hugs,
and this is a milk chocolate
hugged by white creme.
I don't know what that means,
and I also don't really want to taste them
because they look kind of boring.
While I was shopping for these,
I also saw these really,
really cute holiday bars.
So they basically have
build-a-Santa or build-a-snowman.
You break the bar apart
and kind of put all the pieces together
like a puzzle to make one of these.
This is so cute and fun.
Reese's of course have their
own festive shapes, I guess.
Starting down here, you can get the
Reese's peanut butter trees.
Chocolate and peanut butter, obviously.
You can also get white trees,
white chocolate and peanut butter.
This never looks like the shape, right?
Uh, yeah?
OK, closer than they
normally are, for sure.
The Reese's snowman. Get a load of that.
And the big boy, the chocolate Santa.
How many servings do you
think is in here? Fifteen.
Do 14 of my coworkers want
to meet up and share this?
Oh, man, it's dry inside.
Didn't you think it'd be creamier?
No. Reese's has carefully, meticulously
perfected the
chocolate-and-peanut-butter ratio
in its peanut butter
cup. It's all off here.
Also, not available at
the Target by my house,
you can get Reese's
nutcrackers and Reese's bells.
Here we have some After Eights.
Now, I'm not sure if these
are a thing in America or not.
There was a aggressive marketing campaign
probably back in the '60s or '70s
when they really became the thing to give
to your dinner-party guests
at the end of a meal.
It's a lot of packaging.
It feels like you're
playing pass the parcel.
And the chocolates
themselves are dark chocolate
with a fondant mint in the middle.
I mean, these are excellent,
don't get me wrong.
Polling the crew. Would it be weird to eat
a whole box of these as, like, an
evening snack, just to yourself?
Charlie: Yes. Why is
that ... ? That's not ...
Thank you. A bunch of
my friends were like,
"Yeah, I will just buy
a box of After Eights
and just work through them by myself."
They do the classic one,
and you can also get a
selection box as well.
It's a bit of a one-track selection box.
It's just various combinations
of mint and chocolate.
We're sticking on the
theme of mint chocolate
for a little bit here,
because obviously we have
the Terry's chocolate orange in the UK.
We've talked about this in
previous Christmas episodes,
but they've also released a mint ball.
You know, I'm something of an elf myself.
They used to have a slogan which was,
"Don't tap it, whack it."
Ta-da.
Even compared to an After Eight,
that's quite aggressively minty.
We talked about Quality Street
in previous episodes before,
but in the UK, we have selection
boxes around Christmas,
where you get a box that contains
a bunch of miniature
individually wrapped chocolates.
Quality Street is one of the
more popular brands of these.
This one is inspired by the purple one,
which is one of the selection-box
chocolates you can get.
It's a milk chocolate shell
with some liquid caramel
and a hazelnut in it.
And then this one is a collisions bar,
which is where they've taken
basically the same, the purple one bar,
but then collided it with the green one
from the Quality Street box.
And we have even more
holiday-themed treats.
These are all from Little Debbie.
So we have gingerbread men, we
have brownies, we have cakes,
we have more brownies, and Nutty Buddys.
So, it's a wafer bar with peanut butter,
and it looks like it has
some sort of white coating on the outside.
It kind of reminds me of a Butterfinger,
except less good because
Butterfinger has chocolate.
We also have the Christmas tree cakes.
These are chocolate. These
are the classic ones.
I grew up eating these all the time.
We have a couple of brownies.
So, this is the Christmas tree brownie,
and this is the snowflake brownie.
They're iced brownies,
which, I feel like
they're not that common.
And last but not least,
we have the gingerbread soft cookies.
These are cute little
frosted gingerbread cookies.
They're really good, in my opinion.
I know that gingerbread cookies
can be a little divisive.
Percy Pig is a bit of an icon in the UK.
It's a sweet that is
created by Marks & Spencer,
which is an upmarket
grocery chain in the UK.
But I think the cult
following of Percy Pig
kind of extends beyond
the just regular Marks
& Spencer's clientele.
It's hard to exactly describe
the type of sweet that a Percy Pig is.
I'd say maybe like a gummy candy.
And they've released a seasonal version,
which is Merry Percymas,
which is effectively just a Percy Pig
but with a Santa hat on.
But also these are vegan,
which is really impressive
because usually to get that kind of chew
you need some kind of animal gelatin.
I love these things. I
could quite happily sit here
and eat a whole bag of Percy Pigs.
Beyond that, we also have
Marks & Spencer's festive helpers,
which I think is, like, Percy and friends,
as well as Colin the
Caterpillar candy canes.
Colin the Caterpillar has been
somewhat of a divisive
figure in the UK recently.
They found Colin's old Tweets.
[crew laughs]
We have caterpillar cakes
as quite a common thing,
like, for kids' birthday parties.
Marks & Spencer has managed to trademark
the name Colin the Caterpillar
and then were kind of
trying to extend that
to any supermarket that was naming
a caterpillar cake anything
that began with a C,
including chains like Aldi,
who I think had Cuthbert the Caterpillar,
and they've been involved in a lengthy,
very public legal battle over it.
Next up we have Sainsbury's
elf munch mix cereal.
It's a tasty mix of
strawberry-flavored elf hoops,
choco pops, mini cornflakes,
and festive stars.
And you can also get
crackers/chips/crisps-type snacks
for the holidays. So many to choose from.
So, here we got the
Goldfish holiday shapes,
but the cheddar flavor.
Fantastic. The best flavor.
You can also get another
"Elf"-themed pack,
which is the Goldfish "Elf"
maple syrup graham crackers.
We also have the Ritz fudge-covered
limited-edition Ritz crackers.
Cheetos also got in the mix this year
with their snowflake white cheddar
and the Cheetos popcorn,
which is two flavors together
in one thing. Apparently that's holiday.
Oh, my God, I've been eating
Goldfish crackers nonstop
for two weeks because I like them
and my wife thought
she was ordering, like,
a reasonable amount from Costco,
and we got the box that
has, like, three bags in it.
Now, Walkers have released
three limited-edition festive flavors
in what I believe to be
varying degrees of
quality, or maybe sanity.
We'll start with this one, which
is pigs-in-blankets crisps.
Literally just smoky bacon.
Next up, we have a festive turkey flavor.
I think I'm tasting rosemary.
I'm getting herbs from this.
Then I've saved the best for last.
Here we have
Christmas-pudding-flavored crisps.
Christmas pudding in the UK,
for the American viewers,
is usually simmered fruits
which are then kind of molded together.
I don't really like
Christmas pudding anyway.
I just don't want to eat
raisins in crisp form.
Oh. No.
All of these are suitable for vegetarians,
even the pigs-in-blankets and the turkey.
While we're on the
subject of festive items,
Greggs also is a place
that pushes the boat out
around the holidays in the UK.
For those who don't know, Greggs
is a beloved bakery chain.
It started in the north of the UK
but now has kind of made its
way across the whole country.
It's very affordable,
things are cooked hot and fresh,
and it's just very tasty as well.
They have a pretty decent
range of festive items,
and we've got pretty
much all of them here.
We'll start down this way
with the festive bake.
Bakes might be what
Greggs is best known for.
In the UK, a bake is puff pastry
which is then filled with
some kind of filling.
In this case, it's a festive filling,
which I think is a combination
of things like turkey,
gravy, cranberry sauce, and
maybe some stuffing as well.
Man, I love Greggs.
Moving on, Greggs has a
Christmas lunch baguette.
There's cranberry sauce,
some onions in there,
the turkey, the stuffing, and
in this one we have bacon.
And then we also have a vegan option
with some gravy and some cranberry sauce.
It's OK. It's very dry.
Being a bakery, Greggs obviously has
some sweet options as well,
starting with this one, the festive bun.
I have some issues with the naming of this
because this is not a
bun. This is a cupcake.
It's pretty good. It's
a nice moist cupcake.
It wouldn't be a Christmas episode
unless I was mentioning mince pies,
and Greggs does a mince pie.
We've had this discussion
on "Food Wars" Christmas
specials a lot before,
but a mince pie in the UK
is not made with mincemeat.
It is confusing. Some
people actually claim
that the original versions
of this did contain meat,
so that might be where the name came from,
but it might just be one of those weird
British naming conventions.
Somewhat controversially, I
don't really like mince pies.
A lot of Brits love them.
I never really got on with
cooked fruits, to be honest.
Next up, we have this
Christmas tree biscuit,
which is very cute. I
think it's gingerbread.
It is gingerbread. That's pretty festive.
And then finally we have
a Christmas cake slice.
This is kind of similar
to a Christmas pudding
in that it's got lots
of cooked fruit in it,
but, as the name suggests,
it's more of a cake rather than a pudding.
It also typically comes with
this very thick layer of icing on the top.
When I was a little kid
I didn't really eat the cake itself,
but I would go and peel
bits of icing off the top,
much to the chagrin of my grandparents.
This is the Sprite
winter spiced cranberry.
It's their special holiday flavor,
which I think is just Sprite
mixed with a cranberry flavor.
Can I say I don't love Sprite?
I feel like growing up
you were a Sprite kid or a Coca-Cola kid.
It's actually really good!
It basically just tastes like
a fruitier version of Sprite.
Literally like a berry Sprite.
[gasps]
She's beautiful.
Happy holidays.
From myself and the rest
of the Food Wars team,
merry Christmas, happy holidays, and we
will look forward to seeing you next year.
Please leave us a ‘like’ and a subscription
as a very special present for me.